ibram kendi oh i love it i love it when
you are
debating a leftist
sometimes the best thing you can do is
just let him talk
if you j this is this was donald trump's
big problem in that debate with joe
biden is biden was destroying himself he
was undermining all of his own points
but but president trump i guess had been
coached to interrupt a lot and try to
off foot biden and it didn't work if he
just let biden talk biden would have
beat himself in the debate he would have
caused himself to lose that's what candy
did kendy tweeted out
this race hustling con artist ibram
kendy tweeted out quote more than a
third of white students lied about their
race on college applications and about
half of these applicants lied about
being native american more than
three-fourths of these students who lied
about their race were accepted
uh-huh
uh-huh go on
what now what does this mean for your
claim that white people have all of this
privilege in the country and that there
is discrimination in favor of white
people what does that mean you're so
close to getting it ibrahim kennedy but
then he realized he realized he realized
what this means is that there is no such
thing as white privilege in this country
actually there's discrimination against
white people and asian people as well
but notably white people and for some
reason the asians get lumped in with the
whites and so if you apply to college
and you say i'm a white person you are
going to be discriminated against and if
you apply to college and you say i'm a
black person or i'm a native american
person or whatever you are going to be
discriminated in favor of your
application
you're going to receive bonus points
you're going to jump ahead of a white
student or an asian student who have the
same scores and an otherwise similar
resume so ibram kendy realized that he
realized that his whole claim for his
entire
grifting career is bogus and so he
deleted the tweet
then he followed up
because there was a lot of conservatives
jumped on him notably jack posobik was
really just brutal to ibram candy so so
candy follows up he says they lie about
what i said to defend the lying of white
college applicants
no they're not lying they're all we were
just quoting you we were just posting
your screenshot that's not lying that's
exposing exactly what you said verbatim
he said here is their tortured line of
thinking when white applicants think
they have an advantage by lying about
being a person of color then that means
they do have an advantage which then
means that structural racism doesn't
exist nobody you're saying they have the
advantage
you said it you said that when the
whites applied and lied about their race
and said they were black and native
american they did better than than
whites who just apply and say that
they're white
you said that
which means you proved that the
so-called structural racism doesn't
exist and actually it does exist but it
discriminates against whites and against
asians you proved that
jack posobik who is one of the people
most prominently taunting ibram candy on
this point
he tweeted he said hi guys i broke candy
i broke him i'd he the guy was pushing
his stupid
racial theories he's the most prominent
peddler of critical race theory in the
country and then he hoisted himself on
his own petard and then i mocked him a
little and i broke him so then
candy responds he says a white man it
just goes back to this how dare you how
dare you evil white man criticize me a
con artist who happens to be black a
white man is attacking a black person
with lies which are violent
the black person resists the white man
keeps attacking until he declares he
broke the black person that's the
contest seek a book about slavery
in other words if you make fun of me a
grifting
con artist race hustler
on twitter
you are you are no different than us an
enslaver in the antebellum south and i'm
a slave i one of the most lauded fetid
wealthy famous
hucksters in the country
i am no different than a slave
they imagine white people are
disadvantaged while white people are on
the higher end of nearly every racial
disparity they imagine black and native
people have racial advantages at the
same time black and native people are on
the lowest end of nearly every racial
disparity shaking my head okay so
obviously
ibram candy despite his protestations to
the contrary he knows that his first
tweet undermined his entire
thesis he knows that
if he didn't know that if if that first
tweet
did not undermine his hustle
why did he delete it if it was totally
fine and it's oh it's my words are being
twisted people are lying well then why'd
you delete the tweet because you know
that it undermines your thesis
but there is something to this last
point this last point is what allows him
to continue
to push this nonsense and make a
gazillion dollars on his books and his
lectures and shaking down corporate
america and winning all sorts of liberal
prizes
the hustle is permitted to continue
because there are disparities between
racial groups in the country
and white people generally do very well
asians often do a little bit better
asians became white some i don't know
how they became white but they became a
white privilege
it doesn't look like they do but they do
and
black people don't do as well and native
americans really don't do as well
okay so what is that what what kendi is
saying is
there are racial disparities in income
in education in
all sorts of things
so how do you explain it if it's not
because the evil white man is keeping
everybody down and he's an oppressive
malignant force in society then how do
you explain it
and there are there are different
explanations for this the libertarians
say it's all about choice the
libertarians say that different racial
groups
on
by and large make different choices when
it comes to different things at
different aspects of society and this
will lead to different social outcomes
the traditionalists say
that tradition matters the culture
matters that there are these holdovers
from different cultures obviously there
are a whole lot of different cultures in
america and some of them are more
conducive to flourishing in this country
and others are not
the racial essentialists say that people
are just you know entirely different and
it's all biological and it's all in your
dna
so and and what you kenny is trying to
do is suggest that if you in any way
deny
uh white privilege or you know critical
race theory or any of that then you're
just like a evil vicious racist bigoted
sort of person
but you're coming you're coming at the
question from the wrong perspective then
why why do racial groups do uh do
differently in the country i don't know
it's complicated right because it's
complicated i don't know because
different groups have different
practices they have different traditions
they they come from different places
there are different historical
circumstances i'm willing to grant all
of that okay
but the fact remains that when the white
kids lied about their race and pretended
to be from the other allegedly
disadvantaged races they got an
advantage
which means that the structural legal
racism that you're talking about
does not exist as you say it does and
actually it exists in the other
direction
and so if ibram kennedy really wants to
figure out why there are social problems
in the country you need to look
somewhere else
look to fatherlessness look to certain
social pathologies
look to these issues
if you actually want to solve that
problem but even kenny doesn't want to
solve that problem ibram candy wants to
keep making a couple buck a couple bucks
but more than a couple bucks really by
shaking down guilty white liberals and
and hustling them at their corporations
and their schools and their local
governments and he's making a lot of
money doing it he's making a big name
for himself but he's not he's obviously
not solving any problems
okay they've got to invent
the white the white racists
the whites the evil white supremacists
who allegedly run this country they have
to invent them they don't exist
how many of them are there like
like three they don't they don't exist
hey there youtube
ring that bell please please i i want to
be polite please ring the bell subscribe
theoretically you should get
notifications when you do that you
probably still won't but that's that's
okay that's fine you can also go to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe maybe leave a five star
review
we'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]